Camilo and Pablo Dunoyer came to America as
small children with their parents.
My only memories are in this country, there's
nothing out there in Columbia for me.
I do feel like I'm American, I've assimilated
into this country completely.
I mean I've lived here all my life.
In the late 90s their father Roberto was a
government employee
working for Columbia's Finance Minister.
And a local guerilla tied to the FARC was
extorting him.
They wanted him to funnel money to them from
the treasury.
The FARC finances it's operations through
kidnapping, ransom, extortion and drug trafficking.
When he refused to help steal money from the
government, the group threatened his family.
The local police said they couldn’t protect
them,
so the Dunoyers fled to America on a travel visa.
The family has been here ever since.
They own a house.
Roberto and his wife Consuela both work at
American companies and pay their taxes.
Their oldest son Pablo is a college student
majoring in engineering,
and Camilo is a senior in high school where
he was elected prom king.
Neither have memory of their birth country.
But changes in federal immigration policy
mean that this family
will likely be forced to leave America
before the end of the year.
If I were to be sent back there I wouldn't
be able to communicate
I wouldn't be able to live normally, everything,
every opportunity will be taken away
it's not the same there, it's a third world
country over there.
And the possibility of even being murdered
over there is a high chance.
When they arrived, the Dunoyers applied for
asylum.
After a multi-year legal battle, they were
denied
on the ground that Dunoyer’s political
views weren’t the primary factor
in his decision to flee Colombia.
And then through a personal connection
the Dunoyers were introduced to San Diego
Congressman Duncan L. Hunter.
He was moved by their story and agreed to
use a special privilege, called a “private bill,”
that allows a Congress member to request deferred
deportation in specific cases.
Congress members have filed such private bills
on behalf of more than 1,900 immigrants since 1983.
Hunter used the power 13 times in his 28-year
Congressional career.
After he retired, the congressman’s son,
Duncan D. Hunter, was elected to the same seat
and he has continued filing paperwork every
year to keep the family in the U.S.
Hunter, like his father, is a conservative
republican and hardline restrictionist.
Seal off the border first, you have to build
a wall, you gotta do E-Verify
so we know we're only hiring American citizens.
He’s on the record opposing birthright citizenship
and co-sponsored a bill that would reduce
the number of refugees and unskilled immigrants
allowed in the United States.
I would not increase the number of refugees
right now at all
or, period, the number of immigrants coming
into the country legally right now.
Sorry that people come from bad places and
not every place is America.
That's not my fault.
But Hunter believes that members of congress
should have the discretionary power to grant
certain families, like the Dunoyers, political asylum.
It's a power that Donald Trump reined in with
an executive order signed last January
that limited ICE’s discretion to defer deportations,
even in special asylum cases championed by
members of congress.
ICE has to show discretion in cases like these
and discernment.
But discernment is exactly what the Trump
administration hoped eliminate
with its executive order and Homeland security
memo announcing new zero tolerance policies.
I have put in place a zero tolerance policy
for illegal entry on our southwest border.
How do you explain an apparent contradiction
in using your powers as a congressman
to shepherd this particular family through
but on the other hand supported policies that
do make it more difficult for asylum seekers.
I don't see any problem with that whatsoever,
there's no contradiction
I'm elected to use my judgement on these things
and I think it's the same as, we help lots
of veterans
a lot of guys fall through the cracks and
I'm the only one that can help them
and I use my judgement and the staff uses
their judgement here
to determine which of those cases merit the
time and effort to do that.
And this was one of those cases.
To this day, the Dunoyer family receives threatening
letters from the FARC
which are forwarded by a relative in Colombia.
You need to know that our organization is
not played, reads one letter,
we will begin to crush and dismember one by
one the members of your family;
this in order for you to pay what you have
agreed with us.
As a 17 year old reading that someone wants
to basically dismember your family
and that their goal is to ruin your lives
and just make your life a living hell
it's just, it's terrible, it's awful, there's
no way to express it.
ICE is aware of this threat, they've seen
these letters and despite all this
they still want to send us back.
And now Congressman Hunter can no longer protect
the family from deportation
thanks to Trump's zero tolerance policies.
According to the Dunoyers,
an ICE agent told them to prepare to leave
the country within two weeks
following their next check-in with the agency,
which is yet to be scheduled.
What are you worried might happen if you did
have to return to Columbia now?
It's a hard question it is.
How we throw away 17 years into oblivion and
start over it's difficult.
No, I don't know, I don't know.
While Hunter is sympathetic to the plight
of the family
and says he wants to do what he can to help
them,
he remains opposed to any measures that would
make it easier for immigrants to enter the country.
There's lots of people that are seeking asylum
that might not be politicians
but they're fleeing violence, they're fleeing
cartel violence, gang violence-
Everybody's fleeing something.
Lots of these people arriving at the border
might be legitimate asylum seekers
and they're just being either detained or
turned back, do you think that's a problem?
I see what your'e saying, no I don't think
that that's a big problem.
Once again this family got a visa to come
into the United States first.
Do you think that they definition of asylum
should be expanded a little bit to take into people-
No, no I think it's very simple, ICE needs to not
be stupid.
Because you have the same cases when you have
translators from Iraq and Afghanistan
and now Syria and Kurdistan, you have these
translators that have been helping us
and this is really big in Iraq and Afghanistan,
many military officers go to bat
to try to get their translators back over
to the US.
So you would think out of anybody in the world,
who would have frontline permissions to having
asylum and becoming a US citizen,
it's somebody that helped us for years with
the US military,
was seen in their towns and villages in Iraq
and Afghanistan
families being killed, death threats every
day,
everybody knows that they're working with
the Americans.
And they don't get ahead of the normal line,
there are some cases but not all the time
and that's one of those dumb things too, that's
a mistake.
Pablo and Camilo Dunoyer are hoping that somehow
the family will be allowed to stay.
This country has, in a way, given us safety.
And we're thankful for that, we really are,
we can't express that enough
the people who have come out and help us,
people like Duncan Hunter,
it's all the people in this community.
Unfortunately right now the people who have
the power over us
and who hold our lives in their hands aren't
able to see it the way everyone else is seeing it.
And it's very frustrating.